A whole new world,...
...a dazzling place I never knew.
But when I'm way up here, it's crystal clear...
...that now I'm in a whole new world with you.
And you'll never hear the wolf cry to the blue corn moon.
For whether we are white or copper-skinned,...
...we need to sing with all the voices of the mountains.
We need to paint with all the colors of the wind.
Who is that girl I see staring straight back at me?
Why is my reflection someone I don't know?
How do you know he loves you?
How do you know he's yours?
Well does he leave a little note to tell you you are on his mind?
Send you yellow flowers when the sky is gray?
That's how you know.
That's how you know he's your love.